[Music]
when i
lift weights i don't hear things i don't
see things i know it sounds weird but
i'm so focused on lifting
that everything else kind of blanks out
[Music]
when i was super depressed weightlifting
was a reason
to do something i do think it helped me
manage those mood swings
you know being bipolar is something that
i'm proud to say like i'm okay with it
and i would like to erase a stigma on
all mental disorders
[Music]
growing up sports were always pretty
important to my family
and i spent 11 years doing gymnastics
when i was 15 years old i decided to end
my career in gymnastics
and i found crossfit just to stay in
shape through crossfit
my current coach recruited me to get
into
weightlifting competitively and i
decided to
take that on full time from there
i've been weightlifting for about four
years my first national
competition was youth nationals in 2016.
about two years into my career i kind of
realized i could
go places with this in 2018 i had my
first international medals
at the junior world championships and
from there it kind of took off and last
year in 2019
and my breakout year the highlight would
be
my 2019 world championship
last year i had a minor meet in cuba
and i just didn't want to lift i wasn't
feeling motivated i didn't have that
fire in me that i usually do
i bombed out which means you don't make
a lift when i got home i
didn't really get out of bed for about a
week
and i had been dealing with you know
bouts of depression for
probably two years at that point that
was kind of my breaking point
when i decided i needed help and when i
finally went to
the doctor the psychiatrist almost
immediately
recognized my symptoms and i was
diagnosed with bipolar
disorder type 2. one of the first things
i thought was that i'm crazy because it
has kind of been put in my head
that there's a stereotype around people
that struggle with mental health
it didn't take me long to realize that
there's nothing to be ashamed of
and i think i decided very early on that
i was going to share this journey with
others in hopes that it would help other
people
get health faster than i did
once i got help i could go to training
and focus on weightlifting
not on if i'm gonna feel great today or
if i'm gonna feel awful
at this point i'm all but qualified for
the olympics so
i'm really excited to train for that and
i'm hoping to meddle there
and represent the usa for the first time
there are some days that i literally
have to
push to my maximal effort and
be about one rep away from failure and
it's not fun it can be very painful
but you know when it comes down to it
those are the days you get stronger
it's a lot of hard work and then it's
really awesome to just
put everything into those few seconds
that you're competing hey everybody my
name is drew beebe
and i'm here in my terrible home studio
that i've made during quarantine
and i wanted to tell you about our new
podcast called great big story
it's got more surprising and delightful
stories just like this one
so head over to apple podcast to spotify
wherever you get your favorite podcasts
and download
great big story